New York City specifically is paying two
billion dollars to black people who
performed poorly on an old teaching exam
Hispanic people too they wanted to
become teachers and they took this exam
and they failed and they sued and they
said this exam is racist and so they
didn't they didn't become teachers a lot
of them New York City is going to pay
two billion dollars to them some people
who never worked as a teacher will get
more than one million dollars each that
they could even get pensions as a result
of this which will inflate the cost
beyond the 1.8 billion dollars at the
posters reporting and you want to know
the cherry on top of this story they
remade the test it's no longer racist
the test now totally woke liberal
politically correct Progressive racism
free
the scores didn't improve